minecraft is getting its first big
update of 2016 Mojang and Microsoft are
rolling out quote new gameplay
functionality for the windows 10 beta
and pocket edition versions of the block
building blockbuster from what they've
said this adds a whole new level of
creativity to the games the overworld
update adds new redstone components you
can use these to make advanced
contraptions like repeaters dispensers
and trapped chests there's a whole new
world of stuff to build witches are also
coming to the game you can find their
huts and try to steal magical potions
from their cauldrons you can even dip
your armor into the pot to dye it with
new colors and if achievements are your
thing you'll be able to squeeze out
another 170 gamerscore from the windows
10 version on top of the update a
redstone specialist skin pack is also
available for two bucks although two of
the 15 skins are available for free
altogether there will be plenty of new
content to explore in Minecraft if
Microsoft or mojang reveal more will
tell you all about it on gamespot
you